[Music]
well hello there river babes
I'm your host Liana Galera and this is
your Sweetwater secrets after-show for
episode 409 chapter 66 tangerine aka the
mid-season finale and our last episode
of 2019 now this was a wild episode and
I think it's safe to say will never
think of tangerines the same way again I
also don't think that I'll ever think of
this episode again because aside from a
brotherly bonfire it felt like all the
other episodes of season four just
saying now we have so much to go over
today I'm bringing you an exclusive
interview with the core for KJ kami Cole
and Lily talking all about the future of
Riverdale plus we're gonna go over all
of your kisses and kisses so get excited
for that
but first let's quickly recap the five
storylines of the week in the blue and
gold breakdown okay so we're gonna start
off with Ruby Dells very own digital
agency Archie now even though it seems
like Archie's crime-fighting days were
over FP called him out for being the
hooded hero but then in a twist
FP grabbed his southside jacket and
joined Archie for a fight okay but in
true Riverdale fashion someone walked
into pops with a gun and shot FP luckily
he's fine but Archie unleashed his rage
one more time onto Dodger and honestly
it was kind of scary in the end a
strange man walked into the El Royale
claiming to be Fred Andrews his brother
who has never ever ever been mentioned
before tis the season of random family
members joining Riverdale speaking of
let's check on Jughead
our top notch writer won the Baxter boys
contest and was named the new ghost
writer of the series but before he could
accept Jughead decided to track down his
long-lost grandpa and he discovered that
he actually sold the rights to his book
but when he went back for a second visit
Grandpa Jones was gone
jürg signed to the contract and that was
then invited to join the coveted quill
and skull Society
who drama yeah as for Veronica well she
also had a visit from another long-lost
relative sure as she struggled to try
and figure out why her college plans
were falling through Veronica called up
her abuela it's a title tale on her
father's behavior she then put on an
over-the-top performance at labahn Nui
knowing full well that her interviewer
from Colombia was in the audience and
honestly it was just kind of weird oh
and then Hiram patented his mom's secret
rum recipe because of course he did yeah
yeah so let's keep this going an order
of craziness and check in with Betty
so first Betty discovered that Polly
attacked a nurse and then went and
visited her in okay and then Alice
received a cryptic phone call that
hypnotized her into trying to kill her
own daughter how is this happening
Evelyn of course so Charles tried to
help Betty confront her cat killing
Darkseid and honestly I have no idea
what the hell is going on with Betty
anymore and I don't think Alice does
either and last but certainly not least
Cheryl our redheaded Bay unleashed a bug
bomb on Thistle house to try and smoke
out her mother Penelope who was secretly
hiding in the walls
yep that tracks so rather than turning
her in Cheryl's put together like a
weird Council of blossoms to then banish
her mom to the season three bunker then
Cheryl said goodbye tearfully to Jason
yet again in a big bonfire bon voyage
now we're nearly halfway through season
four of Riverdale and at this point I'm
not sure what the future is looking like
so when I caught up with the stars on
set earlier this year in Vancouver I
asked each of them to reveal their
thoughts about what's gonna happen after
season four and just here's what they
had to say I think I've been a senior
three times I'm pretty sure the kids
will have graduated maybe actually we
get held back again I don't want the
kids to be in high school forever
[Music]
we are now in our senior year at
Riverdale high what does this mean for
the future of the show how much longer
do you see it going on as long as the
fans keep watching I mean the show I'll
call Riverdale high it's called
Riverdale so you never know what can
happen off to it's perfect
maybe actually we get held Becky yeah I
mean he didn't really go to school much
his junior year I would not be surprised
I'm surprised he passed junior year are
you sure obviously damn I mean this is
senior year season for one season for
reps I'm pretty sure the kids will have
graduated so as far as where it goes
from here I don't know I think there's
opportunities for the kids to leave
Riverdale but there's also opportunities
for them to stay and I think there's a
lot of unfinished business for a lot of
them and it seems like they might all
feel the need to stay and take care of
things with their family or with their
businesses you know obviously Veronica
has like 12 businesses that she's
running yeah I think Betty probably
wants to stay close to her mom and at
least for a little while they've got
some stuff to figure out I think they're
all gonna take a break year gap year and
like just chill for a minute 100% I
think I've been a senior three times
once in real life and twice on
television I think one of the initial
questions for the abstract of the show
was our week only to age over time and
you know naturally as we grow older and
we look older we had to solve that
problem so it's nice that that we're
aging and it also kind of frees up the
universe a little bit inside Riverdale
to play around with that concept I'm
excited to see where we all go is that
enough for you I don't want the kids to
be in high school forever I think
Riverdale is very much a show about the
cycle of life and things you know
growing up and all of that so I think
it's it'd be really cool to see them go
off to college and grow up and see what
they make out of their lives and maybe
the show ends with someone having a kid
you know who knows why but I'm just
pitching things I'm just like hoping our
showrunner well you know all the varchar
fans are like it's happening yeah not a
drill
what is the craziest fan theory or idea
that they're trying to tell you guys
about fan theories really but I do see a
lot of like fan fiction or just kind of
like yes that wasn't even the characters
I was just my personal life's nevermind
but I do know that he's got a really
weird one it was like all the way to
like me and madelung we're both having
babies and like talking I was just like
a really weird baby sure how many more
secret children should we be expecting I
don't know if I want a pregnancy
storyline I'm just gonna put that out
there you guys have already know my
thoughts about this but I was reading
through the comments because we posted
this interview yesterday and a lot of
you were saying that you would really
hope that we do a time jump after season
four I would love that I think that that
would be a perfect way to kind of get
things back on track so I'm all for like
when Pretty Little Liars did their time
jump or Glee or anything like that like
I'm here for that let's let's see them a
bit older cuz they're already doing
crazy things so all right now let's take
a look at this week's most romantic
moments with seven seconds in heaven
there weren't any again goodness
gracious this is getting ridiculous sure
they all stood around and held each
other while Cheryl set her brother's
already dead body on fire and shoved him
onto Sweetwater River but I wouldn't
really say that was the most romantic
scene that Riverdale has ever had would
you I don't know tell me in the comments
or tweet me right now but let's move on
to my favorite segment and focus on this
week's hisses and kisses now you guys
are already setting in so many crazy
comments right now hello all of my lives
yours watching first off I want to give
my biggest hit of the night and it
sounds like you all had the same
thoughts it's going to that
flash-forward scene at this point I'm
just at a loss for words
so let's rewatch it and see if I find
some
he's dead what did you do Betty
[Music]
no no no I'm not buying it anymore like
if it was something else I don't know
Betty bringing back her dark side III I
don't know we all have a lot of thoughts
on this and I feel like none of us are
believing it anymore I still love the
theory we've been talking about it for
weeks now of that this is a like a fan
fiction come to life almost like that
this is the inspiration for jugheads new
Baxter boys novels I I'm not quite sure
but we have a lot of really great tweets
from you guys first one's coming to us
from at Emma for two two one nine nine
five three and she said hisses - the
writers bringing back the dark Betty
thing and trying to convince us that she
killed Jughead meanwhile she said kisses
to Cheryl for finally being strong
enough to let Jason go god I love her so
much okay yes we all have a lot of
thoughts on Cheryl some of you like last
night's episode and seen her say goodbye
to Jason others not so much
let's take a look at some of our live
comments right now so Lipa decker said
this is - the fact that they still want
to make us believe that Jughead is dead
yeah and a lot of you guys have been
commenting saying they would never cook
kill off the narrator of the show I
don't remember the last time we heard
him narrate the show so that's not
necessarily my big concern for me it's
just that I could kill off Cole Sprouse
Cole Sprouse is Jughead he's part of the
one of the most popular ships I I just
not buying it if it was Kevin
unfortunately I would buy that because
they don't give him up anyways Ava plays
one two three four five said omgomgomg
hi LeeAnn hi Eva I cannot believe I'm
finally going to be taking part in a
live stream I live in Wales UK Riverdale
Ahlers 24 hours after the u.s. Wow
I knew Penelope was involved I just knew
it goodness gracious
Penelope coming back into the picture
the fact that she was living in the
secret room in thistle house like it
tracks was I surprised she came back no
was that glad it wasn't Nana Rose
messing with Cheryl yes so I will take
that
Bailey Bella said his sister Cheryl's
mom coming back kisses to all the
couples at Sweetwater River saying
goodbye to Jason
Shoni bug-head barchi that was really
sweet to see
on the river that sounds really weird to
say that it was really sweet watching
them say goodbye to a burning body but
hey anytime sweet water rivers involved
I get excited and I'm sure you guys know
why okay we're getting in so many great
comments from you guys right now mmm
Nikki Michelle Cole's
said it was so great to see Chuck had an
F P in there serpent jackets again not
sure how I feel about Charles he's a bit
scary but it was nice to see him and jug
for the first time yeah that was very
strange because I was like all right you
guys are half-siblings too I do know
that I have a lot of thoughts and I
wanted to give kisses to Kevin getting
to sing with Veronica finally sweet baby
Kevin had some time in the spotlight but
this whole scene with Veronica singing
in the bong a week in front of her
Columbia interviewer it was just weird
and then I got to give hisses to the
fact that once again it was a Archie
fighting scene mixed in with a musical
moment we have had this so many times
I'm honestly tired of it I'm not tired
of Kevin's voice because it looking at
me so cute but then having arch you just
have this giant meltdown once again like
we we've been talking about how every
week on on in these season 4 episodes
it's the same story lines for each
person they're not crossing over it's
just we have our Archie jug Betty and
Veronica and Cheryl a little bit
nothing's happening
Archie's still having the same fight
over and over again and we actually have
a tweet right now from at herb sista and
she said the same thing
hisses to this app I feel like we're
getting the same storyline over and over
for God's sake can Archie stop using his
fists to solve all his problems
hyrum Indies drama is getting old and
for God's sake well someone really helps
Sheryl she needs professional help I
will say that Sheryl seems to be doing
better after the treatment episode it
was I was a little shocked at first when
it looked like she was committing
suicide yet again with the bug bomb and
then when they showed her in the gas
mask I was just like I mean it makes it
makes sense in Riverdale terms
there's that let's read some more
comments from you guys cuz you guys are
doing a great job Katina Val Cova said
jugheads not dead because in several
interviews the cast is saying that
Jughead was originally written in the
scene by the fire where Betty Veronica
and Archie are burning their clothes I
like that Sonia Quintero says kisses -
tawny topaz for being the amazing
girlfriend she is the hug at the goodbye
to Jason had me sagging or sobbing sorry
not soggy not sure what that is but gosh
tawny topaz once again she said paid in
the episode and we got to know nothing
about her I just I feel badly
Piper Swanson says this is the first
time I've ever been able to make a live
stream I'm excited
elegant vlogs by Maddy welcome back
Maddy said hey great to be back just
want to say talk about how many times I
cried from this week's episode I did not
cry at all I'm not quite sure
maybe I'm just immune to it by now but
there was nothing in this episode that
made me want to cry I I do think the
madelung patch once again did a great
job acting but when I was thinking about
the fact that Jason died and the pilot
of this episode of this series four
years ago and that he's still part of it
now oh I'll cry tears of relief but
that's finally put to bed how about that
miss Friends fan forever what is up with
all those musical numbers why is
Veronica putting on a number when she
has a college interview camis a good
singer no doubt about that that it's
just weird fact that tracks I think I
don't know I don't know we also have a
tweet right now from at show need a
apprised
and they said kisses to that dead body
gone hallelujah
kisses to everyone getting a random
family member except Tony let's talk
about all of our random family members
in this episode along alone it was nice
to see Veronica's grandma come back that
was sweet mister shouldn't really do
anything
Jughead finally met his grandpa and
basically he disappeared also let's talk
about the fact that Jughead was staying
in the same bus where the gargoyle King
hung all those little things in season
three we had a lot of repeat sets in
this episode like for example let's take
another tweet from at
help how eight one two three and they
said hisses - Penelope blossom what a
witch kisses - Sheryl for locking her in
the sex bunker you guys remember the
season three sex bunker remember the
season three romance scenes you guys we
actually had romance on the show and we
felt like it was yeah lookit I forgot
about this set but they did not and and
goodness gracious
I don't know but I do know that you guys
still have a lot of thought so I'm
excited
okay mmm Andrea Renata Gomez said kisses
- LeAnn oh thanks you're finally getting
a vacation for all the craziness that is
Riverdale I can't tell you I'm a little
bit excited that we're getting a bit of
a break right now because I I'm really
hoping that next half of season four is
not this wheel on a hamster I want high
school scenes I want the Vixen I want a
football game they were supposed to
Roberto told me at Comic Cons that we're
supposed to have our cheese start a band
called the our cheese but he's been just
been fighting people every single week
how does Archie keep not getting killed
in these fights I there's just so many
things you guys there's so many things
Nadia Webber says kisses - Cheryl
finally burying her brother and hisses -
there being a Riverdale community
college how have we never heard of it
before I mean if they all end up at
Riverdale Community College I don't know
what I'm going to do that's why I would
like a time jump let's get past college
let's see who's still together who's not
we can fill each other in I think that a
time jump at this point would be
sensational and and after season four
that's what I'm rooting for you guys
tell me if you agree but yes a lot of
people you guys say are a lot of people
are saying how convenient it is there's
a community college hmm no um let's see
Kathryn Edelman said am I the only one
that noticed that Dagwood was in the
background in the first scene when
Penelope woke up with Cheryl and the
others in the living room probably I was
just so concerned that they still had
the doll and Jason's dead body and then
there's Tony Josh Blackman would it be
opposed to a VAR chi and bug head baby
but later in the series
we've already had Polly have babies and
Alice had babies young I don't need
babies also it's hard to work with
babies it's not fun for the actors it
makes the show completely different
unless we're just never gonna see them
like the twins has anyone seen the twins
anyone Kayla Rose
I don't think Betty did it no way
obviously she's talking about the
flash-forward scene I don't think so
either
maybe it's like a hypnotist thing maybe
all this is just like visions I don't
know then the end cow hisses - another
Veronica song while Archie fights
sequence I thought we were done with
those no we are not I would like to be
better parent Josh Blackman not buying
the jug his dead four weeks later or
that Betty all of all people would kill
him yeah yeah and then we also have a
comment from Ashley Smith and said Brett
doesn't take rejection well Brett
doesn't do a lot of things I just can't
anymore we're gonna be good thank you
all so much for watching the sweet
letter secrets after show for episode
409 chapter 66 tangerine and now I'm
dying to hear more of your thoughts
about season four so far so hit the
comments or tweet me what do you really
think about season four are you hoping
for more character crossover I am do you
think we'll actually see the kids do
something school related I don't which
random Riverdale relative is making you
roll your eyes the most time twister and
do you remember when there was romance
on this show tell me everything I hope
you all have a happy and safe holiday
[Music]